Gut.
Ja, das ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistentarzt tätig.
Ich würde mit Ihnen in dieser, das auch das Aufnahmegeschef dafür
bevor wir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerde kommen, soll ich ein paar Frage
zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Sind Sie damit ein Verständnis?
Ja, ja, es geht um mein Sohn hier, der nicht bei mir habe.
Ja.
Okay, okay.
Falls irgendetwas unklar ist, fragen Sie gerne nach.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Sohn heißt Marvin Engelt.
Marvin Engelt.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Sohn vor und nach Namen bestabieren?
Können Sie bitte den Vor und Nachnamen Ihres Sohnes bestabieren?
Ja.
M-A-R-V-I-N.
Marvin ist der Vornamen und der Familienname ist Engelt.
E-N-G-E-L.
E-N-G-E-L Engelt, ja.
Wie darf, wie darf zu Ihren Ansprachen?
Ich bin Frau Engelt.
Frau Engelt.
Ich bin die Mutter, ne?
Ja, Frau Engelt.
Wie alt ist er?
Ja, er ist neun Jahre alt.
Neun Jahre alt.
Wann ist er genau geboren?
Am fünften Februar 2016.
2.06, 2.06.
Ja, wie groß ist er?
Er ist 1,31 m.
1,31 m.
Wie viel wiegt er?
Wiegt er?
28 kg.
Ja.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Welche Beschwerde hat er?
Ja, also ich mache mir jetzt doch große Sorgen um den Marvin.
Er hat jetzt schon ein halbes Jahr lang immer wieder so Durchfälle.
Er ist ja sowieso schon ein bisschen vorherkrankt.
Er hat eine bekannte Zuckerkrankheit.
Sie sind Diabetes-Tip 1 und er bekommt regelmäßig Insulin.
Aber jetzt hat er immer solche Durchfälle.
Und er hat auch Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, er gefällt mir eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
Er ist ganz schlapp, er geht mich gerne zur Schule.
Und die Lehrerin sagt auch, er ist ganz teinnamlos im Unterricht.
Und ich habe das erst auf unsere familiäre Situation zurückgeführt,
weil ich mit meinen Mann und ich, wir sind geschieden.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, ja, vielleicht macht ihm das zu schaffen.
Und er will deshalb nicht in die Schule gehen, aber es scheint doch irgendwie
noch mehr dahinter zu stecken.
Ja, versteht.
Seit wann hat er diese Beschwerde?
Ja, also eigentlich aufgefallen, dass er so über Bauchschmerzen klagt.
Ja, es ist so rund ein halbes Jahr, kann man sagen.
Halbes Jahre.
Waren Sie beim anderen als wegen dieser Beschwerden?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe jetzt immer gedacht, wie gesagt, er macht mir nur was vorher.
Er will nicht zur Schule, aber jetzt habe ich doch das Gefühl,
dass da mehr dahinter steckt.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch etwas Beschwerden bemerkt?
Ob ich noch weitere Beschwerden bemerkte?
Also Fieber oder Übelkeit, Übelkeit, Fieber, Übelkeit, Erbrechen.
Also Fieber habe ich mal gemessen, weil ich dachte,
ja, er ist so schlapp, aber Fieber hatte er nicht.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass er sehr häufig auf die Toilette geht.
Also er muss sehr häufig Wasser lassen.
Und ja, was mir auch so ein bisschen Sorgen macht, er gedeiht irgendwie so gar nicht.
Also er hat auch wieder Gewicht verloren.
Er hat jetzt irgendwie drei Kilo abgenommen in den letzten Monaten.
Ich wiege ihn natürlich nicht so oft, er ist ja schon groß.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Sie haben gesagt, Gewicht verlosen und mehr mal auf die Toilette gehen.
Wie viel Mal ist am Tag?
Muss er auf die Toilette?
Wie oft am Tag muss er auf die Toilette gehen?
Ja.
Ja, also wenn andere Kinder vielleicht fünf Mal gehen, geht er vielleicht doppelt so viel oder so.
Okay.
Also acht Mal, zehn Mal ja.
Haben Sie etwas unauffällig bemerkt in seiner Stuhl?
Zum Beispiel Blut oder Schleim oder Farbeveränderung?
Ja, er hat ganz heftige, ganz heftige wässrige Durchfälle.
Ja, aber Blut ist da nicht drin.
Also da habe ich schon auch mal nach geguckt, aber die Idee wäre ich jetzt eigentlich auch nicht gekommen.
Ja, wie viel Kilogramm haben Sie bemerkt und welche Zeitraum?
Also ich denke in den letzten halben Jahr hat er drei Kilo abgenommen.
Eigentlich nehmen Kinder ja zu in dem Alter.
Ja, das ist unangenehm.
Ich verstehe.
Ja, haben, wo genau sind die Schmerzen lokalisiert?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Also er zeigt immer auf den Bauch, aber ganz genau kann ich das nicht sagen.
Das müssen Sie vielleicht dann bei der Untersuchung rausbekommen.
Okay.
Schittralen, die Schmerzen, irgendwelche Körperteile aus, hat sie etwas gesagt?
Hat er etwas gesagt?
Nein, er sagt immer nur, er hat Bauchschmerzen.
Aber wie gesagt, sagen ja viele Kinder, wenn sie keine Lust haben, in die Schule zu gehen.
Deswegen haben wir das gar nicht ernst genommen.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, dass die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Ja, also oft ist das so, wenn wir Nudeln gegessen haben, dass er dann hinterher sagt,
ist das so furchtbar gerne, dann ist er vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen zu viel und dann hat er halt hinterher immer kräftige Bauchschmerzen.
Das ist schon so, ja.
Ja, kräftige Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, hat er Schlafprobleme?
Schlafprobleme?
Ja.
Nein, eigentlich würde ich das nicht sagen.
Eigentlich kann er ganz gut schlafen.
Gut schlafen, keine Übelkeit, keine Erbrechen, Sie haben gesagt.
Appetitlos ist er aber, dass er mir schlecht ist im einen, ich in Sinne eigentlich nicht und übergeben musste er sich zum Glück auch nicht.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Ja, ich würde wissen, ob er eine chronische Erkrankung leidet.
Sie haben gesagt, Tip 1 Diabet leidet.
Genau, ja.
Er, seit wann?
Oh, das hat man festgestellt vor so 2-3 Jahren.
2-3 Jahren.
Er splits in Syrien jeden Tag.
Ja.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Ja, ich hatte so ein Thema, aber das habe ich jetzt zu Hause gelassen, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay.
Leidet er noch andere chronische Erkrankungen oder?
Ja, lang, mir weiß Gott hin.
Ja, also, sonst war bisher eigentlich, ja, eigensinnig klar, was das Essen angeht.
Der mochte nie gerne Obst- und Gemüseessen und Diät halten, ist ganz schwierig, aber...
Also, sonst war er eigentlich mit dem Diabetes jetzt ganz gut eingestellt.
Ja, gut.
Nehmt er regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf noch andere Medikamente?
Nein, um Gottes Willen, das ist ein Kind, der kriegt dort keine Medikamente.
Ja, ich weiß gut.
Wurde er schon, wurde bei ihm schon einmal operiert?
Ja, er hatte einmal einen Leistenbruch auf der rechten Seite und das ist dann, also, wieder
gerichtet worden, das musste man operieren, er war eingeklemmt.
Seit wieviel Jahren?
Vor wieviel Jahren?
Vor wieviel Jahren wollen Sie wissen?
Entschuldige, Operationen.
Vor wieviel Jahren, das war, ja?
Ja.
Vor zwei Jahren.
Vor zwei Jahren, okay, verstehe ich.
Okay, leidet er an Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Bisher ist mir da nichts bekannt, dass er auf irgendwas Allergisches.
Okay.
Sie leiden an chronische Erkrankungen, leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Also, ich habe so ein bisschen geilen Probleme, ja.
Geilen Probleme?
Aber ich bin noch nicht operiert worden.
Ich habe geilen Steine, aber bisher ist noch nicht operiert worden.
Seiner Vater?
Nein, er weiß nicht, dass er einen hohen Blutdruck hat, ja.
Blutdruckdruck.
Haben Sie noch andere Kinder?
Ja, Marvin hat noch ein Bruder.
Ja, ist er gesund oder?
Ja, ja, dem fehlt nichts, ja.
Okay, gut.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen für mich gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich finde natürlich gerne wissen, was das sein kann und wie man dem Marvin helfen kann.
Ich mache mir natürlich Sorgen um ihn.
Ja, wüsste schon gerne, wenn er in der Schule fällt, er ja aus und fällt ja ja auch auf,
dass er keinen Spaß hat und so.
Und insofern möchte ich natürlich, dass er wieder fit wird, ja.
Ja, ja, das ist zu früh zu genau Diagnose zu sagen.
Aber ich denke, eine Zoliake Probleme, eine Bluttonunvertäglichkeit, vielleicht.
Aber sollen wir zuerst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen, ein Parla por
untersuchen und vielleicht bildgebende Verfahren durchführen?
Ja, was für Bildgebung, kann man denn machen?
Ja, vielleicht Bauchultraschall.
Bauchultraschall, das ist ja ohne Rangestrahlen, ne?
Ja, ja, ohne Strahlen.
Ja, das können Sie dann ja ruhig machen, ja.
Ja, nachdem alle Ergebnisse abgeschlossen sind, können wieder über die Ursache
seiner Beschwerde sprechen.
Ja, das klingt gut, mir.
Gut, hat noch jemand Fragen an die Mutter von Marvin?
Hat er Hautveränderung?
Ja, also er hat tatsächlich seit zwei Wochen an den Oberarmen
auf beiden Seiten ausschläge, wo ich nicht weiß, woher die kommen.
Aber sonst ist mir eigentlich keine Hautveränderung aufzufallen.
Ja, eine Sache ist noch, dass ich das Gefühl habe, ich weiß nicht,
ob er sich an den Haaren reißt oder so, aber seine Haare gehen irgendwie
stärker aus zur Zeit.
Ach, das ist ein Tumgeruch.
Hab ich jetzt nicht festgestellt, ich wüsste aber auch nicht, wie das riecht.
Leidet er unter Yukrides?
Ja, also wie gesagt, an den Oberarmen hat er an beiden, auf beiden Seiten
so einen Ausschlag, wo er sich auch juckt, aber sonst ist mir das eigentlich nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie eine Auslöser dafür bemerkt, so wie eine stressige Situation,
so wie eine Reise vielleicht?
Ja, ich habe ja vermutet, dass seine ganze Geschichte zusammenhängt
mit unserer Ehelscheidung, dass er eben unglücklich ist über die
familiären Verhältnisse und das so ein bisschen abarbeitet,
indem er sagt, er hat Bauchschmerzen, aber es ist mir jetzt doch ein bisschen viel geworden in letzter Zeit.
Und dann wurde jetzt gerade gefragt, ob ich den Blutzurkermesse, also ja,
natürlich riecht der Stuhl unangenehm.
Ich glaube ja, kann man schon sagen.
Mein Stuhlgang riecht nie besonders gut, aber das riecht schon unangenehm.
Sie sagen Bescheid, Doktor Seidel, denn das ist so weit sind, ne?
Ja.
Geht es, kann er losgehen oder noch nicht?
Ja, ich kann.
Sie kann, Gott, nein, legen wir los.
Ja, ich möchte einen neuen Patient vorstellen,
Herr Marvin Engel ist ein neunjähriger Patient
in leicht untergewichtigen Ernährungszustand und deutlich reduziertem Allgemeinzustand.
Die Anamnese wurde von seiner Mutter erhoben.
Der Patient stellte sich im Begleitung seiner Mutter, unsere Klinik,
mit seit einhalb Jahren bestehender Persistieren, die Füsse Abdominalgie und Diaryofor,
die von Fatig begleitet sein.
Laut seiner Mutter hat er innerhalb vier Monaten oder einhalb Jahre
von drei Kilo abgenommen.
Er hat letztens drei Kilo abgenommen.
Die Bescheiden seien nahrungabhängig und insbesondere,
so wie Nudel, wurde die Bescheiden verstarkt.
Durch Nudelessen von Nudeln wurden die Bescheiden verstarkt.
Er leidet unter Appetitlosigkeit.
Die Frage nach Fieber, Überkeit oder Erbrechen wurde verneint.
Die Anamnese ist auf oben genannte Symptome unauffällig.
An vor Erkrankungen leide er, gibt ein Diabetes-Melütus seit zwei, drei Jahren,
die mit Insulin eingestellt worden sei.
Er sei vor zwei Jahren wegen Ingüinel-Herrni eine Operation durchgeführt worden.
Er wurde vor zwei Jahren wegen einer Ingüinel-Herrni operiert.
Auf die Frage nach Allergien, Noxen und anderen Medikamenten wurde verneint.
Die Anamnese hatte eine Schokolassistolitiasis bei der Mutter.
Der Vater des Patienten leide an Arterielle Hypertonie.
Er hat eine Bruder. Er ist gesund.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben durften am Ehesten auf eine Zöljacke hin.
Alternativ kommen in Betracht Gastroenteritis und chronische Darmentzündung.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Die Abklärung sollte die folgende tropatische Massnahme durchgeführt werden.
Zuerst körperliche Untersuchungen, insbesondere Bauchabtasten.
Die Bauchabtasten werden durch Schmerzen abgeführt.
Außerdem hört man die Darmgeräusche.
Man hört auf die Darmgeräusche und erwartet auf die Darmgeräusche.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen und Laboruntersuchen durchführen.
Wir machen eine Stuhluntersuchung.
Wir machen eine Ultraschalluntersuchung.
Wir brauchen eine Stuhluntersuchung.
Es gibt noch Antikörper, die man bestimmen kann.
Ich erinnere daran nicht.
Ich habe Ihnen nur die Antikörper gegen Blutzen.
Was erwarten Sie für Werte des Blutlabor?
Ich erwarte eine Anämie.
Wir machen die Untersuchungen weiter.
Wir machen die Antikörper gegen Blutzen.
Was ist die Therapie für ein Kind?
Die wichtigste Sache ist die Patientenschulung.
Wie soll eine besondere Diät empfehlen?
Eine glutenfreie Ernährung.
Ausreichender Philosophie ist wichtig.
Wo ist die Gluten in welchem Lebensmittel?
Die Gluten sind in besonderem Volkorn- oder Nudeln.
verbrochen, die nicht. Also keine normalen Nudeln, kein Brot, keine Backmahl. Es sei denn, es ist eben
glutenfrei. Aber Mais geht, Reis und Mais gehen, Kartoffeln gehen und Hirse geht erstaunlicherweise
auch. Und ja, und das Kind soll natürlich Obst und Gemüse essen und Fleisch eil weiß. Aber eben
keine klassischen Allgemeinbackwahn und eben aufgrund der ja immer wieder sehr unklaren
Zusammensetzung keine Fertiggerichte. Man muss also immer frisch kochen, sozusagen.
Wie lange muss der denn
diese glutenfreie Kosten nehmen? Ja, lebensjahr. Lebenslang. Ja, genau. Ja, gut. Ich glaube, wir
können das hier gut ablesen. Ja, Sie halten mich auf dem Laufenden über die Ergebnisse.
Ja, gut. Aber stationär aufgenommen werden muss der Junge nicht. Der ist nicht so schlecht,
dass er nicht so schlecht. Ich denke, wir brauchen keine stationäre Aufnahme zu erst. Sondern nur gute
Beratung. Die können ambulante Behandlung durchführen. Ja, gut. Ja, eigentlich gibt es nicht viel zu klagen
über ihr Anamnese-Schema. Das war alles okay. Was ihn natürlich ein bisschen eine Überraschung
bereitet hat, war die Tatsache, dass es eine Fremdanamnese war. Ja, und da mussten
sie sich erst mal zurechtfinden. Und ja, bei Kindern sagt man eben nicht, es handelt sich um Herrn
Marvin Engel. Sagt man, es hat sich eine Mutter mit ihrem Sohn vorgestellt, dass der junge Patient
als Marvin Engel ist neun Jahre alt. Ja, aber das war natürlich auch eine Überraschung, dass
da mal ganz was anderes kam. Ja, und dann muss man aber natürlich auch sagen, ja, also die ananästischen
Angaben wurden von der Mutter gemacht. Ja, und natürlich kam man bei einem neun Jahre alten Kind
schon auch selber mit dem Kind reden und sagen, wo tut denn weh? Oder ist dir doch irgendwas aufgefallen?
Ja klar, aber das gibt natürlich unsere Prüfungssituationen nicht her. Gut, was mir nicht so
gut gefallen hat, die Mutter hat ja eigentlich selber so ein bisschen Schuldbewusst auf diese
bisschen prekäre soziale oder familiäre Situationen hingewiesen. Ja, und hat ja auch
gedacht, dass das Kind sich in der Schule auffällig verhält. Ja, dass die Lehrerin sagt, der ist
überhaupt nicht bei der Sache, der ist so unkonzentriert und so. Und das finde ich,
sind schon auch wichtige Informationen an den Kollegen dann, dass man sagt, ja, also es ist
nicht nur der Mutter aufgefallen, dass es dem Kind nicht gut geht und natürlich auch diese Frage,
warum kommt die erst nach einem halben Jahr? Ja, warum lässt sie das Kind so lange vor sich
hin krank sein? Ja, und das ist eben diese Situation, die Mutter hat eigentlich schlechtes
Gewissen wegen der familiären Situation, Scheidung, alles misst, ja. Und was weiß ich, hat das Gefühl,
sie kann sich nicht richtig um ihre Kinder kümmern oder kann den Vater nicht ersetzen,
oder was auch immer und hat das alles in die Richtung geschoben, dass der aber tatsächlich
auch eine körperliche Erkrankung hat, zusätzlich zum Diabetes. Auf die Idee ist sie eben nicht
gekommen. Ja, gut, ja, was sie auch nicht erzählt haben, dem Oberarzt oder der Oberärztin,
dass häufige Wasser lassen. Haben Sie sie schlicht vergessen, ne? Ja, ich werde gestern. Ja, das hätte
noch bei der vegetativen Anamnese eigentlich reingehört und auch, dass der ein schlechter
Esser ist, dass er also längst nicht alles ist. Ja, das ist eigentlich natürlich blöd,
ist für ein diabetes Kind, wenn man dem, also ja, nur Kohlehydrate gibt. Gut, aber okay.
Ja, was auffällt, dass sie, ich glaube, das habe ich Ihnen beim letzten Mal auch schon gesagt,
dass sie so eine ganz gradlinige Sprachmelodie haben, dass, dass ihre Ressetze keine Bögen machen.
Normalerweise hören wir ja den Punkt, ne? Wir fangen mit der Stimme unten an und dann sprechen
wir und machen dann einen Punkt. Das heißt, unsere Sprachmelodie macht so einen Bogen und
sie sprechen immer in einer Art und Weise, dass das eigentlich ohne Punkt und Komma geht und man
weiß nie wann ein Satz zu Ende ist. Hören Sie den Unterschied? Ja, und das macht sie ein bisschen
schwer verständlich. Das kann man eigentlich nur durch lesen, so ein Laut lesen, kann man das so
ein bisschen üben und auch wenn jemand da ist, der sie korrigiert. Ja, dass sie, dass sie, also
ein bisschen, wenn sie eine Frage haben, was hat das Kind denn heute gegessen? Ja, dann gehen sie am
Ende mit der Sprache hoch oder wann sind die Beschwerden denn am stärksten? Ja, aber der Frage
gehen sie in der Satzmelodie am Ende hoch und wenn sie einen Satz formulieren, sagen wir so.
Danach werde ich den Marvin Bluth abnehmen. Danach werde ich den Marvin Bluth abnehmen und
dann werden wir, ja, das ist, da hört man den Unterschied zwischen den einzelnen Satz nicht.
Das kann ich Ihnen nur zur Verständlichkeit und ja, um das so ein bisschen normal Deutsch
klingen zu lassen. Ja, man hört es, den Akzent hört man bei Ihnen tatsächlich noch sehr, sehr stark
raus. Ja, und Sie machen eben auch noch, ja, Grammatikfehler, wo ich dann gleich eingeschritten
bin. Ich habe es Ihnen ja gleich dann gesagt, dann muss ich sagen, Sie meinen das und das, ja,
ja, mache ich selber auch, machen Sie aber auch relativ häufig. Das ist aber ein Klassiker,
machen wir alle. Das ist so ein kleiner Pausenfüller und manchmal auch so etwas, um die Gedanken zu klären.
Aber man sollte das nicht übertrieben machen, ja, also suchen Sie auch auf die Amst dazwischen
so ein bisschen. Dann machen wir, das sollte man ein bisschen reduzieren. Hören Sie vielleicht selber
nochmal rein. Sie können, glaube ich, in die Ausnahme reinhorchen, dass Sie das nochmal nachverfolgen
mit der Satzmelodie. Wie klingt meine Stimme? Ja, dass man, dass man ein bisschen mehr Betonung
reingekommen. Sprache ist auch ein bisschen Musik. Ihr Kollege gibt eine freundliche Mitteilung. Also,
das ist inzwischen schon viel besser geworden ist mit der Sprachmelodie. Ich habe es nicht so
offensichtlich gesagt. Ich könnte jetzt den Vergleich nicht anstellen, aber vielleicht haben
Sie schon häufiger zusammengesprochen. Gut, ja, ich glaube, so viel kann ich Ihnen für heute sagen.
Ja, Fremdanamnese, ich weiß gar nicht, die kommen vor in der Prüfung, aber ich glaube sehr,
sehr selten. Nur irgendwann muss ich auch mal meine Fremdanamnese loswerden. Ja,
die anderen Fälle sind alle schon ziemlich abgenudelt. Da haben wir schon so oft gemacht. Aber
diesen Jahr haben wir noch nicht so oft gemacht. Und wie gesagt, es kann Ihnen passieren, dass
eine Fremdanamnese kommt, ist nicht ganz ausgeschlossen. Es kann einmal bei Kindern sein,
natürlich insbesondere bei Säuglingen. Dann kann Ihnen das auch passieren bei
dementen Altenleuten, dass da Angehörige mitkommen und dann sagen, ja, Vater redet nicht mehr oder
was auch immer. Und dann muss man eben auf die Situation eingehen, laut Angaben der Mutter
oder laut Angaben des Begleitenden, im Sohn des Tra-la-la besteht das und das. Gut, da kann man ja
so ein bisschen eine flüssige Formulierung sich auch nochmal für den Fall überlegen. Ja, gut,
seien Sie gewappnet, was auch immer kommt. Für heute würde ich sagen, ich verabschiede mich.